we just broke the story of who the first
three uh people who got sickened by
covid were they were three people
working in the Wuhan Institute of
virology we have from multiple sources
within the US government the names of
these individuals we broke the story
with Matt taibi as a joint project with
racket in public we've had incredible
access to whistleblowers and Witnesses
because we stood up to members of
Congress who berated us publicly and
people trust that we will protect our
sources huge story on Twitter it had
been viewed according to the the public
count over 5 million times I shared it
on Facebook and five people total not
five thousand not five million five
people total had shared it with me with
under a hundred comments I mean it's an
explosive story and it was absolutely
being censored and suppressed on
Facebook